over or 2.75 should we cut this?
Like a quarter inch more?
Sorry what?
How much more than 2.75 should we cut this at?
The what sorry?
Quarter inch more?
Okay so here's our plan.
Cut this in the band saw, the pieces, and then we're going to drill out on the lathe, the interior hole.
And then we'll also turn out on the blade the plugs.
Yeah.
All right, so we've got all that cut.
Now we have our three three-inch pieces.
And then this is about one and three-eighths, I think.
That's what I measured it to.
So we just left some extra on then so we can turn off the edges, make them flatter and more exact.
Cool.
I'll get it just a little bit.
That's all you need, huh?
You just need a guide holder.
This is the first one.
We cut the ends so they're flat on both sides and now it's perfectly at 2.75 inches.